III is on in two weeks time and sunday
June fourteenth bethesda will be kicking
it off with a brand new press conference
showing off a bunch of exciting new
games from those folks Justin hey Walt I
niebaum when Chris waters we're here to
talk about some of those games we know
about and some of them we don't know
about at first off they've been doing
one of these trailers a week so to last
week they showed off well they showed
something of that doom 12 seconds of
yeah caga demon Joan Reverend revenant
revenue side blood on the stuff here we
go the second that trailer thousand done
yeah and 24 christx I'm gonna see magic
one doom doom yeah sure on a that
doesn't like my fire there's other
things in the pathetic wanna budget
we'll get back to that then he's excited
42 alright he was think about too ok
alright so this shows just have a quick
on way back did last year people
apparently lost their beep for it but
[ __ ] my fans right yeah so maybe
they're a little over excited but who
knows this can be good one thing to take
note a guy named chair go salsa or
something like that he was the head of
R&D at Crytek he jumped ship as that
ship was kind of blue already went to
it'd maybe he's working on int X 6 who
knows cuz he's like a big cry tech guy
see they what if they doom it takes 6
and big announcement III could be cool
are we excited about in tech I don't
know maybe say maybe doom has got some
sweet treason to shape them they chopped
in half bean trees and graphics baby
Justin you excited for it did you see
the other trailer for doom where they
took the trailer that they made but did
it in the original style oh really now
so is the exact same like doom in the
old school about that today just a demon
in it is kind of doing as a few sprites
or enemy yeah yeah really funny yeah
we're gonna see doom doom presumably
they're going to have some sort of
single-player component where you're
running around chillin overloading no
reloading so they said yeah [ __ ] we
loading but I 59 guns have gone past the
point requiring to be reloaded who needs
it do you expect some sort of
multiplayer stuff into I'm kind that's
kind of an I'm so excited about is like
an old quake fan I hope to god because
that's something that's been sorely
lacking although they're all these i'm
reading shoot is coming out now and like
early access like toxic and whatever the
other ones and technical term
yes like yeah and how can I do was the
last multiplayer game the Bethesda even
release like besides elders all right
right week cousins uncles yeah that's
true uh Tamriel unlimited but yet I but
there's a sort of online shooter game
does it even was this talk of any so6
it's right here so this is a since gone
have free to play I guess right he the
man on to yourself alright right now
they won't let us know hey well it is
now we free to play game right you have
continued to play it you can continue
playing without paying money I'm so free
to play that's actually not a free to
play game you can purchase it you do
have to buy the game so it's not free to
play in the sense that a lot of other
games are you just downloaded and start
playing you still have to purchase the
game but if you purchase it already you
don't have to continue thing this is no
subscription yes it's fee to pay so it's
basically like every other video game
you buy us and then you can play it and
you can play as long as you want
imitative oh come on console next week
right what if that launch goes badly and
that like their press consoles gonna be
colored weirdly it's like they're having
with their game and they're like trying
to put on TV it's even gonna register on
the problem you don't think so yeah just
doesn't think so that's the thing it's
these MMOs tend to have troubles at the
beginning because you just have an
influx of millions of people who want to
try it out for the first time we already
had that with all the scrolls online now
it's coming to console and you know
we'll probably be a good uptick of
people trying it out but not too many
yeah it's not going to be enough to
crash their servers I wouldn't all right
we are four minutes into a video about
the Bethesda conference we've mentioned
in the scrotum and we still haven't
mentioned fallout for our boy here look
at that crates dudes the guy it's a guy
who's not so usually behind the I can
just find out tomorrow are they as so
today a fallout ticker appeared on the
Thursday's website here it is as it's my
baby 16 hours until we get an
announcement about a fallout game we
know it's a fallout game now yep fall
out boy scarin the worst-kept secret in
the past couple of months in the video
game industry so but my thought is that
they're going to follow the blizzard
model and it's going to be a collectible
card game no they're going to follow the
Elder Scrolls model and it's going to
come out in November yes or the excom to
model are like hey I'm out notes nova or
the elders
model and take it on la oh well they
have the rights to the online version
right now they were like made sure to
get that just in case they want to do a
demo ZeniMax hot it and they have that
there was a court case over this has got
to be my mentee Howard's team toddy how
yeah and I don't think he's going to do
a memo the what does that team been
doing since sky really they've been
working on their sweet quests and follow
with three dog I don't know what's his
day I wrote his name down because I
really wanted it doesnt sit Eric tenens
but yeah oh that's a question do you
think it will have any online component
at all obviously with skyrim they proved
like Bethesda like really down with just
making the massive single player game no
on lines fine I think they'll go the
unknown on line roof I think like as
much as that seems to be somewhat of a
trend like look at a game like The
Witcher like the way that game is online
is dlc and I think maybe if they lean
into the mod stuff on PC would fall out
that would be cool and if they keep
releasing DLC like they're DLC game with
those get with those titles has been
tremendous oh yeah all that fall three
deals a position you'll see like they've
been on point with that for a decade
like oblivion has a real assurance armor
sharing okay horse armor you know you
gotta break some eggs mad and make a
delicious omelette through future get in
there everything broke why fix it yeah
totally yeah so yeah fallout hopefully
we'll know more about that tomorrow
where is it each one each one each just
emerged ticket said as a Boston like all
the rumors were two years ago no no
definitely not Boston said on the moon
set on the moon credit go for it I think
it's gonna be Boston you think Boston
yeah oh yeah I don't know man give me
the Bay Area take place with some
geographical interesting stuff going on
Boston has got islands and like flat
lands now you notice coupe watchdogs to
that's gonna be in the Baron all right
there all right let's see what over
games they got dishonored to what do you
think oh so there's a pretty credible
rumors site but german pc games I sounds
credible yummy no they've been right
about some stuff VG 24 7 reported on the
roof leaks doc de bak cuz he gave that
de they don't think they're gonna have
much a t-34 dishonor to maybe a teaser
at most okay but [ __ ] that make checks
out but does disappoint me greatly
because dishonored is breaking up I feel
like they're gonna have yeah at least a
teaser I think it has to be acknowledged
this is a game that like of many of the
says does sort of new IP effort so
the past five years this is far and away
the most successful and they have said
themselves that you know they think they
have an IP here Arkane Studios is hiring
for someone for team to work on
unannounced Triple A game currently uh I
hope they got to give us something and
you don't have a press conference for
one game as big as all out is gonna have
a lot of titles don't know man you could
have a press conference for food i watch
Doug press conference acid about dude
and they got fallout they might have
dishonored talk about good as sort of
second swings at new IP what are the
odds of us seeing something to do with
pray to no no but that game is done and
gone yeah they were really explicit
about it not being a development last
October but what if it better have a
machine games logo like that one like I
wanna have ya know I'd be too early
cause you're never does anything you
know they're going to go get Martin but
I Justin do you think there's no chance
that maybe they showed that old project
and they took it up somewhere I would
not be surprised to not hear anything
okay a couple legged very right there is
a elephant in the room that we've missed
and they're gonna have to talk about
because they're putting money and I go
for it it's a little game called battle
cry battle cry i confuse battleborn know
by the prior barson battlefield field 33
MOBA and I'm not moma but action game
harsh done by the guy who did half life
2 yeah so it's it reminds me the
southern game called gigantic which has
been around a lot of you like packs and
stuff um I think it's an alpha at this
point this game will probably be an
alpha at some point because it's
multiplayer focus they don't balance
stuff they can let people in who knows
what its gonna be free to play or not
but you be able to play this at events a
quite common inaugural tournament I know
that much yeah I think I played it as
well last year last yeah I didn't think
many people got their hands on its got
like abilities that you pop off with
like II and cute and kind of like
overwatch but it's not first-person yeah
yeah so I would not be excited for this
maybe they'll show it all as an audience
at Thea maybe they'll announce game of
theirs it will surely be any nitrous
cars okay how about some other games
they haven't announced that they
couldn't answer let's go through this
real quick actually I'm going to pick
one for each of you Justin hey wold Wes
oh oh boy just remember what exists
Wednesday one Westerner game wet wet to
wetter the weather the wettest the
wedding what do you think no no is equal
to wet no no they're rebooting it is dry
at brink 20 men if only tango GameWorks
was working on a horror version of brink
to they did it was called brain oh
there's a sales hard ring to does exist
it's called dirty bomb and dilatation a
drink that's true or or what was the
zombie I can't think of which ones which
anymore dying lying like a peasant
passed on Splash Damage when they're
buying up studios they were like oh yeah
you made bring sorry and the last one on
their on their list i guess is
Wolfenstein you think we'll see anything
they've already shown the old he logs so
maybe what the old blood was just a
month ago it probably still be too easy
I what I would be surprised to see
another DLC chunk like the old blog more
Wolfenstein like I kind of doubt it what
do you think Annie you drop the name a
few times so far tango gameworks that
you know within Shinji Mikami well are
they done with their season pass for
that like this deal see all wrapped up
yeah we thank you final one it's gonna
walk a miquela I mean we've all kind of
forgotten about it but they'll probably
show something if they're like here its
expansion do you'll see or something is
like cheating more evil within I don't
know yes because that's the way the
video game industry works great good
look forward to a kids don't worry about
all have fallout stuff the evil within
new information coming soon a Bethesda
reeling back the years with a Adam
Sessler and Morgan Webb gonna be hosting
their pre and post-show as well it's
gonna be like old times and that's going
to be on Sunday June fourteenth make
sure you say that gamespot com for all
the news on that all right we'll be back
in a second with some [ __ ] chatter about
our good friends over at Microsoft the
first or the second of the two big
console amount of fractures we to talk
about sorry to try to stick with us be
back in a minute
you
you